all right true uh it's broken in green
bay between aaron rodgers and
the packers
jordan love
who had a rough
outing
his first day of the mandatory mini camp
all of a sudden the tweets were coming
fast and furious from the beat writers
who were watching practice on wednesday
jordan love looking pretty good jordan
love starting to figure it out jordan
love getting it done here's jordan love
after practice on wednesday talking to
reporters about how he's feeling now
that he's had even more time as the
number one guy in green bay
my mind said this whole offseason has
been to get ready and get myself ready
and that's
been my mindset since i got here and
you know whether aaron was here or not
here that's going to be my mindset
regardless because i have to
get myself ready to play i just been
living my life man just
trying to do what i can do to to get
better um in this off season and
obviously
you know not knowing what's gonna happen
next you know just gotta
um
my main thing has been controlling what
i can control and uh you know do my best
to like i said get better every day um
so that i'm ready you know whatever the
circumstance may be come season
just do my best to be ready for myself
for the team and for everybody here um
yeah and uh the other question yeah me
uh
obviously me and aaron we got a good
relationship um talked to him
probably a week before i got out here so
yeah
managed to get through that with any
face touching or other tells but there
was at one point
you could see by the eye movement and
just the general exasperation
we know what he's been going through
yeah i feel for the guy right definitely
he is in a no
win
situation
get ready you don't know when the guy's
coming back you got to be ready to go
everything you do is going to be
scrutinized at a level that no other
first round quarterback faces because
none of them potentially are replacing
one of the all-time greats at a time
where we're not sure whether or not the
all-time great is going to come back and
you know frankly the better jordan love
performs maybe the more likely
the all-time great comes back who knows
what's going to motivate aaron rodgers
at this point but i really feel for
jordan love and i think anything that he
does that looks good that passes the
eyeball test that gets those reporters
to check boxes for hey he looks great
hey how about that throw hey that that's
even more impressive than it would be
for any other quarterback given
the stress that is inherent to his
current predicament no doubt about it i
mean there's i don't think there's more
of a spotlight on one player in the
whole nfl more than than
jordan love that's for sure you know and
again like yeah it's a tough spot you
know hopefully he does have a good
relationship with aaron rodgers because
aaron rodgers at least went through
something similar to a degree not quite
like this but maybe that could help him
with his own mindset of mindset of how
to approach this situation and
everything like that but like one i'm
like mike first off like the reports
like you mentioned the tweets everything
like that i'm not surprised to hear that
hey it's the second day right maybe they
added a few new plays into the offense
that caught the defense off guard he's a
little bit more comfortable you know of
course wide receivers and everybody else
are comfortable too and here this is the
other part that you know maybe i hang
around with you too long okay
um and and maybe i look too deep into
things but i also know this is the nfl
and this stuff goes on
like the
the packers saw the tweets from two days
ago about practice not being you know
all that awesome by jordan love miss
throws the front office saw that they
hear the chatter the coaches hear the
chatter so i would also think there was
a concerted effort
one you know to make the player look
good so he doesn't have so much pressure
on him but just to you know shut up the
outside noise a little bit to where
maybe they did draw up a few plays and
you know ooh got the defense in just the
right play for that play like i've
talked about to at least put him in a
position to take advantage of something
big and maybe you know frame the
narrative a new way the next day i don't
put that past them i'm not trying to be
a jerk by it it goes on all the time and
uh that's one of the first things i
thought of when i saw some of that stuff
yesterday
i think it's a fair take you've pointed
out in the past that in new england they
don't call defenses that are catered to
allowing the offensive play to work the
offense is on its own in practice but if
joe berry calls a defense knowing what
the offensive play is going to be
knowing that that defense sets up the
offensive play for success and allows
the packers to generate
some of these tweets that will maybe
make jordan love look better make him
feel better spin things in their favor
exactly i look i you do it right i do it
i i i i don't know that i would do it
per se i can't fault them for doing it
yeah i can't fault them for doing it not
not after the way things went on tuesday
and they understand exactly how high
stakes this all is right and that's the
thing there are no accidents in any of
this yeah there are no mistakes in any
of this when mark murphy writes in a
column that the aaron rodgers situation
has divided our fan base that's not
something he just blurts out and he
wishes he could take back that's the
product of careful thought and strategic
planning everything that's happening
here is a result of strategic planning
just like as i wrote last night at pft
when james jones continues to say the
situation is fixable yeah that is the
result of strategic planning by aaron
rodgers to make it look like the packers
are at fault for not fixing it it's very
simple it's fixable it's fixable the
packers haven't fixed it blame the
packers it's no big deal it's not about
this it's not about that i'm not going
to tell you what it's about but it's no
big deal yeah it's fixable they can fix
it and he'll be back i think he'll be
back for training camp like yes yeah i
agree with you you're exactly right
everything is strategic here i think so
you know just like you have influenced
me over the last four years to say
things like mega horn my cynical nature
has influenced you yeah to to realize
and you would you don't need me to
realize it's yep they're going to try to
prop their guy up they have to exactly
exactly you know i i mean i you know
i've seen john gruden do it i've seen
him have conversations with the
defensive coordinator like hey man you
know i got to get this guy some
confidence right he'll he'll talk like
that or whatever it is i could totally
see that going down nate hackett matt
lefleur having a conversation with joe
berry hey play this coverage why we run
these plays you know and then i have
friends that ask me and go well why
would the defense do that though that's
not good for them and i go yes it is
still good for them and you have to
understand why a little bit yeah like
joe berry might not want to play that
exact defense versus that formation
right but during the nfl season at some
point his defense is going to get
tricked and that they're going to motion
or do something he's gonna get stuck you
know in that in that defensive setting
with that formation he doesn't like to
go against and now the defense at least
gets to work on it and go see this is
where we're vulnerable when we play this
so we have to learn to do this and make
a little you know tweaks to the rules of
the defense and things like that so it
still benefits the defense even though
they're letting up a big play on seven
on seven and a mini camp or anything
like that it's a learning tool
and then also an offensive confidence
booster for the quarterback the
receivers whoever it may be and i think
that it'd be something i would do i
would be thinking that if i'm an
offensive coach with the packers right
now hey let's get everybody off this
kid's back a little bit let's get him
some confidence you know it's hard
enough let alone we got the media
tweeting out you know live events about
him missing throws and things like that
and and i i could certainly see that
going down or at least i'm having that
conversation
i doubt chris there was a single tweet
about the guys who got burned the guys
who got beaten the guys who were out of
position when jordan loved exactly right
those guys aren't the focal point of
everything that's happening in green bay
and another way to justify it is we owe
it to this kid to help him we put him
in this spot we drafted him into this
mess the mere act of drafting him helped
create
this mess regardless of anything that
aaron rodgers is saying to james jones
with the idea that james jones is then
going to turn around and say it on radio
or tv of course that was part of this
the way they handled it what it shows
whether it's the symptom or the cause
it's part of the problem and jordan love
is in
an extremely difficult position so they
owe it to the kid to give him a positive
debt to make him and they need him to
they need him to build confidence if
he's good at some point he's going to be
the guy maybe this year right maybe next
year maybe the year after they can't
ruin him in a mandatory mini camp
practice by letting him just flounder
and and and get to the point where he's
got no confidence at all he's got to
have some leadership at some point
though chris here's jordan love from
yesterday talking about his approach to
leading the other players who will be on
the field with him
that's a part of my game that i'm trying
to improve as well
just being able to take charge of this
offense and
you know be able to command these guys
and uh take leadership
uh role but uh yeah i mean like you said
last year obviously i wasn't in that
role um
you know that was that was aaron's voice
being heard and uh what not but now i
just gotta be able to you know take that
next step and uh take command of it and
leave these guys and you know
it makes sense
why are you gonna try to lead when the
guy who's been the leader since you were
10 years old exactly or younger right is
is there he's not there you're number
one on the depth chart while he's not
there you've got to provide the
leadership it's that simple and it can
be awkward at first because you know
people develop their narratives they get
used to what they've seen oh there's
that guy who was quiet all year last
year oh wait a minute he's talking now
oh boy i kind of like what he's having
to say but that that's part of what you
have to be as a quarterback you know
when it's your moment right yes to step
up when you know when it's your moment
to shut up and you know when it's your
moment to step up yes that's right and
step up and then start to learn the
different or get a feel for the
different phases of that leadership i
think that's the next thing like you
know again like devonte adams and and
the rest of the offensive line and david
bakatiari they don't they don't want to
hear like a rah-rah speech from jordan
love right now right right right that
would be like wait dude you're not to
that leadership level yet you haven't
played in the game you haven't even
dressed for a game yet but like where it
starts is hey yeah command of the
offense he knows what he's doing and
then the knowledge within the offense
that's how he's going to start his
leadership role you know the guys break
the huddle valdez scandlings like what
what he's hey double wing right you're
over here get in the slot you know four
yards off the tackle there he gets them
right like that then players start to
listen wait this guy knows what he's
doing okay and then the next thing that
comes you know is you got to see the
results and things like that so that's
how the leadership is formed as far as
the quarterback position and yeah this
is a great experience for him to kind of
show his knowledge his command of the
offense that he can you know handle the
the pressure in the heat of the
situation and direct everybody the right
way and then as he gets to play and
practice and play in the preseason he
could start to even if aaron rodgers is
there just assert his voice little by
little you know here and there without
kind of you know uh being disrespectful
to aaron rodgers and and hopefully he's
learning that he's got a great way about
him as you could see that's for sure and
i do think the kids got natural
leadership abilities just at least a
little i've heard behind the scenes
how did it work for you when you showed
up as a rookie in 2003
uh take me through that progression you
know you're you're the guy who's who's
making sure warren sapp has his cans of
copenhagen right to eventually becoming
the guy who's taken over the team like
total backseat is what i did i mean yeah
just hey whatever i can do i want to
learn let me show you i'm willing to
work you know and be a good teammate so
i was always you know
following brad johnson and brad johnson
and sean king you know who the hell was
i to think that i should be in front of
them on the depth chart one guy just won
the super bowl the other guy played in
the nfc championship game like three
years before that so i really just took
the approach of let me be one of the
guys let me show them that i love
football and i love to work at it and
slowly you start to gain the respect and
like you know like i was just saying
then they see me playing pre-season like
oh hey this this tall blonde kid he's
yeah he's a knucklehead but damn he's
pretty good he likes football and you
know you start to create your niche on
the football team to where the next year
you know in year two i kind of was a
little bit i don't want to say it a
quarterback competition but a little bit
they were telling me hey you might have
a chance to start this year or do
something like that brad didn't play
great i didn't think i would start but
at least i was able to
you know assert myself to a to a degree
without trying to be disrespectful to
brad johnson again who a guy was really
good and good to me and then when i got
my chance you know to play and do that
then i could kind of show everybody my
real self and maybe yeah yell and be a
little you know rah-rah-ish a little bit
more that way but yeah you gotta you
gotta take it in steps in the locker
room if you go too quickly people will
disrespect you not like you and and shut
you out and be like oh gosh he's all
talk shut up he hasn't done anything yet
one thing that you said there that
struck me the opportunity you had as a
rookie to play in the preseason and
develop a niche that way jordan love
didn't i know right i know he's even
more of a disadvantage exactly was just
the guy who was there never in uniform
speaking of uniforms i always heard that
brad johnson at half time of the game
would take off
the uniform he wore the first half and
put on an entire new one is that true
well listen nobody could sweat like the
we call them the bull brad johnson
could sweat like no other my first
training camp ever
like our our second day at camp we're
having double sessions i mean i remember
hearing a yell throughout the hallway of
our hotel in orlando it was brad johnson
on the floor in a full body cramp he
couldn't move they had to like get ivs
up there and do everything so yes in
some of the hot games he would change
some of his clothes and then we had
swamp ass at center right and john wade
and he used to make john wade change his
pants at halftime because like the ball
was a wet watermelon by the end of the
half and he would do that and john wade
would be in there all mad and taking it
off and you could see he was pissed off
that he had to do it and all that but no
that is real brad early in the year he
would definitely wouldn't change his
whole uniform but if he felt like his
pants were like excessively soaked or it
just the jersey or whatever then yeah
he'd make a change that way
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports